Robert Mugabe.
Hailed as an anti-colonialist hero; despised
as an autocrat and dictator.
At the time of this video production, Robert
Mugabe has just recently died, aged 95, after
37 years as the Prime Minister, and then President,
of Zimbabwe.
The news of his death had barely become public
when many of you asked us to cover his life
story and career.
Here, we’ve obliged.
Robert Mugabe’s rise to power is a similar
story to that of many rulers in the de-colonisation
period.
A story of a struggle for independence, a
quest for national unity and societal development.
And then: a gradual descent into autocratic
rule, economic chaos and violence.
A Student and a Teacher
Robert Mugabe was born on the February 21,
1924 in Kutama, not far from Harare, now the
capital city of Zimbabwe, but formerly the
administrative centre of Southern Rhodesia,
a recently constituted, self-governing British
colony.
At that time, political and economic power
was firmly in the hands of the white minority,
some 270,000 citizens who controlled the most
fertile land.
Conversely, six million locals were pushed
into the colony’s driest regions, making
a hard living from subsistence farming.
Young Robert was educated in a school run
by catholic missionaries, and was by all accounts
a studious and hardworking child.
He later recalled that he enjoyed solitude,
while looking after a herd of cattle in the
sole company of a book.
Robert’s father, a carpenter, abandoned
the family when the boy was only 10 years
old.
That same year, Robert’s elder brother died,
allegedly from a poisoning, which plunged
his mother into a deep depression, interrupted
only by violent mood swings.
In addition to looking after their farm and
attending school, Robert had to look after
his mother.
He developed a strong bond with her, to the
extent of being bullied for being a ‘mummy’s
boy’.
Robert continued his studies into higher education:
from 1950 to 1952, he attended Fort Hare Academy,
in South Africa, thanks to a scholarship.
In this period, he started to develop a political
conscience, influenced by socialism and anti-colonialism,
inspired by a desire for independence from
British rule and by a will to break down racial
divisions.
Apartheid was becoming a tangible reality
in Rhodesia and in neighbouring South Africa,
and Robert found inspiration in Gandhi, Nehru,
and the struggle for Indian self-rule.
Robert eventually graduated as a teacher,
the first of many academic achievements: in
later years, he would attain degrees in law,
administration and economics.
The same year, 1953, saw Southern Rhodesia
merge with the British protectorate of Northern
Rhodesia.
The resulting Federation of Rhodesia and Nyasaland
was still under British colonial administration.
Robert soon became ‘Mr. Mugabe’ to his
students, after taking a series of teaching
positions, first in the North of the federation
– a territory which later became Zambia
– and then in Ghana.
Mr Mugabe’s experiences in Ghana were life
changing.
On a personal level, he met and courted a
colleague, Sally Hayfron.
The two married in 1958.
On a political level, Ghana was an eye opener
for the young teacher: the West African country
was already independent, a first taste of
life free from colonial rule.
He was deeply impressed by the policies of
Ghana’s first president, Kwame Nkrumah,
and his brand of ‘African socialism’.
This ideology embraced established aspects
of socialism such as communal land ownership
and planned economy, but fused them with private
initiative, an acceptance of individualism,
and a revival of pre-colonial African culture.
Mugabe returned to Rhodesia in 1960.
Inspired by Krumah, and encouraged by Sally,
he took his first steps into anti-colonial
activism.
He started campaigning against the discrimination
of the black majority, which granted him an
invitation to speak at a rally of the National
Democratic Party, or NDP.
The party leader, Joshua Nkomo, was impressed
by the teacher and hired him as publicity
secretary for the NDP.
Unfortunately, this alliance of two strong
personalities was doomed to failure.
A Slow Rise to
the Top
The leadership and membership of the NDP mirrored
the make-up of the black population in Rhodesia,
as it was divided into two main ethnicities:
the Shona majority and the Ndebele minority.
Nkomo, and most of the leaders, belonged to
the latter.
In 1963, the Shona clans rebelled against
Nkomo, led by Reverend Ndabaningi Sithole
and by Mugabe himself.
The reverend and the teacher formed a breakaway
faction, which became the Zimbabwe African
National Union, or ZANU.
The strong anti-colonial stance of the ZANU
became a cause of concern for Rhodesian authorities.
In 1964, they cracked down on the party leadership.
Mugabe, Sithole and other activists were convicted
of acts of sedition and sentenced to harsh
prison terms that could extend up to 11 years.
The bitterness of incarceration was only made
worse by news from outside: Mugabe’s only
child had died in Ghana in 1965, and he had
been denied leave to attend the funeral.
During the same year, Rhodesia broke away
from the British Empire, becoming an independent
country, albeit without international recognition.
Power remained firmly in the hands of the
white minority.
The struggle of Mugabe, the ZANU and the NDP
shifted in focus: the priority was no longer
independence from the British, but rather,
an established government led by the black
majority in the country.
While in prison, Robert Mugabe made the most
of this time by further advancing his education
and preparing for total leadership.
By the early 1970s, Mugabe was still playing
second fiddle to Rev. Sithole, but trouble
was stirring.
Other party members, also incarcerated, accused
the Reverend of cooperating too closely with
white authorities, in exchange for prison
privileges.
Sithole was eventually ousted and Mugabe swooped
in, becoming the head of ZANU.
In 1975, after the end of his prison term,
Mugabe fled to Mozambique with the help of
a white nun.
There, he joined the ZANLA guerrilla force
that had been harassing the Rhodesian government
since 1964.
This was part of the Rhodesian Bush War, also
known as the Zimbabwe Liberation Struggle.
Let me tell you, this was a very complicated
war, so get your notepads out.
On one hand, you had the Rhodesian Government,
hampered by UN sanctions because of the lack
of international recognition, but supplied
in secret by the South African Government.
On the opposite corner: the ZANLA, force,
or Zimbabwe African National Liberation Army,
affiliated with ZANU, the party of Sithole
and Mugabe.
The ZANLA operated from Mozambique and was
supported and supplied by China.
In the third corner, there stood ZIPRA, the
Zimbabwe People’ Revolutionary Army, operating
from Zambia.
Their backers were the Soviet Union and their
political leader was Joshua Nkomo, who had
now founded his new party – ZAPU.
[Caption: Zimbabwe African People's Union]
Interesting to note: the ZANLA/ZIPRA dichotomy
reflected the larger Sino-Soviet split, a
major turning point of the Cold War.
But let’s stay grounded in Rhodesia.
Mugabe did not actively participate in the
fighting; his role was more political.
He was the voice of the ideology who would
motivate the fighters and swell their ranks
through propaganda and recruitment.
It is generally recognised that ZIPRA was
in fact more of an active military force,
while Mugabe’s ZANLA was more interested
in sowing dissent and disobedience inside
Rhodesia.
The complexity of the situation was thankfully
reduced when Mugabe and Nkomo were forced
by their followers to accept an uneasy alliance,
the Patriotic Front.
The two leaders did not actively cooperate,
but simply accepted each other’s existence
and avoided infighting across their separate
factions.
While the insurgency versus the Rhodesian
government continued, the stage was being
set for a future conflict between the two
rebel leaders.
A CIA analysis noted how the two tried to
upstage each other: Mugabe visited Havana
in July 1977 to seek support from Fidel Castro,
and possibly extend a hand to the Soviets.
This worried Nkomo, who also flew to Cuba
in November of 1978 to prevent the rival from
snatching Soviet favors.
But the war was finally nearing its end.
In late 1979 the British government mediated
a peace deal between the Patriotic Front and
Rhodesia.
This agreement put an end to the war, sanctioned
the independence of Zimbabwe and pushed the
relatively obscure Mugabe front and centre
on the International stage.
In early 1980 Mugabe returned from his exile
to Harare and called for the first democratic
election of the newly independent State of
Zimbabwe.
Mugabe was one of the candidates, of course,
and he became Prime Minister with a 57% majority.
One step at a time, the former teacher had
reached
the top.
The Rain and the Chaff
Was Mugabe’s victory a fair and transparent
one, as ruled by British observers?
Well, Mugabe had certainly built a following
as a liberation hero and he could rely on
the vote of the Shona majority.
But it is also claimed that Mugabe’s guerrilla
fighters intimidated many voters into picking
the right candidate, by forcing them to attend
indoctrination sessions, called ‘pungwes’.
Mugabe’s rule was marked by similar crafty
methods.
His first rival, Joshua Nkomo, was invited
to join the newly formed cabinet, as Home
Affairs minister.
Generous, right?
Well, yes, but actually, no.
Nkomo’s powers were purposefully reduced:
he was denied any authority over rural local
government and, very importantly, over the
Special Branches of the Police.
Nkomo was a minister with no muscle.
This move was however in line with Mugabe’s
public face: the face of reconciliation.
The young State was rife with divisions.
Mugabe vs Nkomo.
Shona vs Ndebele.
Black vs White.
And yet the Prime Minister invited everybody
to “Remain calm.
Respect your opponents and do nothing that
will disturb the peace.
We must now all of us work for unity, whether
you have won the election or not”.
Speaking of Unity, Mugabe was steering Zimbabwe
into becoming a one-party state, under the
ZANU-Patriotic Front, or ZANU-PF.
And a one-party state could not tolerate opposition.
So, despite all the grand talk and overtures
to former rivals, Mugabe was preparing to
crack down hard on Nkomo and his followers
in the Ndebele minority.
In August 1981, Mugabe invited military instructors
from North Korea to train his crack troops,
the Fifth Brigade.
They would be known as Gukurahundi, a Shona
phrase meaning:
“the rain which washes away the chaff”
This phrase would become the name of their
more infamous operation, as we’ll hear in
a minute.
In February 1982, a police inspection discovered
a cache of arms hidden in a farm, owned by
one of Nkomo’s companies.
This was the perfect pretext to accuse Nkomo
of plotting a coup, and to remove him from
the cabinet.
Next, in January 1983, Mugabe unleashed his
full-scale offensive against Nkomo’s followers,
the Ndebeles living in Matabeleland, or western
Zimbabwe.
The Fifth Brigade, the Rain, swept through
the region and washed away what Mugabe considered
to be the chaff.
According to a report from Zimbabwe’s Catholic
Commission for Justice and Peace, the Brigade
was responsible for mass murders, beatings
and property burnings in the areas where Nkomo’s
supporters lived.
Within six weeks more than 2000 civilians
had died, hundreds of homesteads had been
burnt and many more thousands of civilians
had been beaten.
Most of the dead were killed in public executions
involving between one and 12 people at a time.
“Villagers frequently report being forced
to sing songs praising ZANU-PF while dancing
on the mass graves of their families and fellow
villagers, killed and buried minutes earlier.”
The operation in the west escalated into a
full genocidal massacre: the atrocities continued
until December 1987, when Mugabe and Nkomo
reached another tentative reconciliation.
By then, it is estimated that between 20 and
80 thousand Ndebele civilians had been murdered.
Executive President
While the atrocities went on in Matabeleland,
Mugabe was consolidating his grip on power
in Harare.
In 1985 Zimbabweans had been called to vote
for a new Parliament.
The white minority was constitutionally granted
20 seats in the Chambers and in that year,
Ian D. Smith’s party won all 20 of them.
Mr Smith had been the last white Prime Minister
of Rhodesia, one who had vowed that the black
majority would never rule his country.
Perceiving this as a threat, Mugabe sought
to reinforce his power base as much as possible:
so, he dissolved what little remained of Nkomo’s
party and merged it with his own ZANU-PF.
With an unbeatable majority in Parliament,
Mugabe in 1987 moved to legitimise his lone
leadership.
He managed to win a majority vote ratifying
a change to the Constitution: this amendment
eliminated the largely ceremonial President’s
office, and created a new, much more powerful
position for himself – Executive President.
A title which combined the roles of Head of
State, Head of the Government and Commander-in-chief
of the Armed Forces.
In case some have not realized yet, Mugabe
had just legitimised his own dictatorship
over Zimbabwe.
And yet, this was also his period of maximum
popularity, both at home and abroad.
Mugabe dedicated enormous slices of budget
to education and healthcare, his policies
managed to revive the economy and develop
urbanisation in the Country.
He even introduced anti-corruption laws, known
as ‘leadership code’: this limited ZANU-PF
cadres from owning more than 50 acres of land.
Zimbabwe was rapidly developing and Mugabe
has also private affairs to take care of.
In January 1992 his wife Sally died of kidney
failure.
In 1996 Robert Mugabe married his second wife,
Grace Marufu, a former secretary in the presidential
office and 41 years his junior.
Mugabe and Grace had had an affair since at
least 1990: their first child, a girl called
Bona was in fact born on that year.
According to him, Mugabe had asked Sally’s
approval.
Their marriage was childless and he wanted
to sire a child before his own mother died.
Baby Bona could be counted among the so-called
‘Born-Frees’.
These were the new generation of Zimbabweans
born after the dissolution of Rhodesia.
Many of them were ready to enter the labour
market at the end of the 1990s.
Having benefited from Mugabe’s increased
spending on education, they were now realising
that the country could not offer them the
quantity and quality of jobs they were trained
for.
The Born-Frees lent their support to a new
party, the Movement for Democratic Change,
led by former labour leader Morgan Tsvangirai.
Mugabe was about to face a new decade of turmoil.
Land grab
In February 2000 Mugabe called for a referendum
to ratify a new Constitution, which would
have solidified even more his grip on power.
The President was expecting an easy victory,
but the Movement for Democratic Change, more
and more popular, gave him defeat in the polling
stations.
Mugabe could not accept this and accused the
MDC members of being lackeys of the white
farmers, who had in fact openly financed the
party.
The white minority of farmers and entrepreneurs
made an easy target for the leader, who had
always ruled on a platform of anti-colonialism
and anti-capitalism.
This minority was so small that it could hardly
pose a threat – about 70,000 citizens over
a total of 13 million.
And yet Mugabe accused them of being dangerous
agents of British colonialism.
Things got even worse for Mugabe when the
June 2000 Parliamentary elections marked a
relative victory for the opposition: the MDC
did not win the majority of seats, but with
a good 57 out of 150 they could leave a mark
on legislation.
It seems like 2000 was the year in which the
President could not catch a break.
Another group raised their voices in dissent:
the veterans of the war of independence, theoretically
great supporters of Mugabe, but now disgruntled
as their pension funds had been embezzled
by corrupt officials.
The veterans sought compensation by forcibly
occupying farms, most of them operated by
the white minority.
Mugabe went with the flow, encouraging the
vets to claim the lands as their own.
From his perspective, this must have been
an easy alternative to actually having to
sort out an alternative pension fund!
Ironically, redistribution of land had been
one of the priorities of Mugabe’s government
after independence.
And yet the issue had just sat there for decades.
Neither Mugabe, nor the white farmers, not
even the British mediators, apparently were
interested in sorting it out.
In 2000, a full twenty years after independence,
4,500 white farmers still owned more than
50% of Zimbabwean farmland.
It seems like the uprising of the veterans
finally gave Mugabe the motivation to complete
the land reform – in the worst possible
way.
Mugabe’s tacit consent to occupy the farms
soon turned into active complicity.
His supporters organised armed squads to invade
the farms and chase away their white owners.
Over the following two years, almost all the
white-owned farmland had been redistributed
to 300,000 black families.
Many of these farms were assigned to competent
commercial farmers, but many others went to
reward Mugabe loyalists, who had no experience
nor interest in working the land.
To use a Maoist analogy, this great agricultural
leap forward eventually caused more problems
than benefits.
Many farms fell into disuse due to lack of
modern equipment, fertilizers, efficient irrigation
or just plain incompetence.
Food shortages became common in the country,
although the Government painted them as a
consequence of drought.
Other leaders of the African Union started
to pressure Mugabe into revising his policies
or even retiring.
But Mugabe would cling like a barnacle to
his Presidential seat
“I am not retiring, I will never, never
go into exile.
I fought for Zimbabwe, and when I die, I will
be buried in Zimbabwe, nowhere else.”
In 2008 a new season of elections proved to
the world how tough could this barnacle be.
In March, opposition leader Morgan Tsvangirai
claimed victory in a presidential vote.
But Mugabe claimed that there had not been
an official vote count yet.
This was delayed for weeks, until Mugabe’s
officials announced that there hadn’t been
a clear victor.
The authorities scheduled a further round
of voting.
But in the lead up to the vote Mugabe’s
security forces launched a campaign of intimidation
against the opposition party, the MDC.
This went as far as beating and killing opposition
supporters.
Tsvangirai had no choice but to seek refuge
in the Dutch Embassy in Harare, from where
he announced his withdrawal from the election.
In the subsequent round of voting, Mugabe
was the only candidate.
Unsurprisingly, he won with 85% of the vote.
As he had done in the past, Mugabe sought
to neutralise his opponent by absorbing him
into the cabinet: Morgan Tsvangirai was sworn
in as Prime Minister, although it was clear
that the executive and military power was
fully concentrated in Mugabe’s hands.
In the following 2013 elections, Mugabe, no
surprise, was the clear winner again.
They may as well printed polling cards saying
“Who do you want as President?
A) Robert Mugabe in a grey suit?
Or B)
Robert Mugabe in a blue suit?”.
It is clearly both, as a blue suit is not
appropriate for evening social engagements.
But the point is moot – by this time Mugabe
had famously ditched formal suits for colourful
outfits and loud headgear.
Whatever he wore after his victory, President
Mugabe decided to end his arrangement with
Tsvangirai, which returned to the opposition.
How to Ruin a Country
I am going to backtrack for a moment now to
take a close look at Zimbabwe’s economy
under Mugabe in the early 2000s.
He had always been an autocrat, but at least
in the 1980s and 1990s some of his reforms
had ensured better standards of living for
Zimbabweans.
But after the ousting of the white farmers,
Mugabe’s economic policies became farcically
incompetent.
The collapse of Zimbabwe’s farming system
had a negative impact on the rest of the economy.
As food became scarce, its price increased,
while farmers had less cash to spend on goods.
Moreover, Mugabe had involved his military
in Congo’s Civil War – a conflict so complex
I will not even try to explain it.
As the government got deeper and deeper into
debt, Mugabe’s central bank reacted in the
worst possible way: quantitative easy.
That is, printing money – to pay off debts
and compensate the war veterans who had not
benefited from land distribution.
As any citizen of the Weimar Republic could
tell you, this can only create catastrophic
inflation, which hit the rate of 231,000,000
percent.
The currency had to be issued in notes as
large as the 100 trillion Zimbabwe-dollar
bill.
In US dollars?
That’s 40 cents!
The increase in prices had also affected housing.
Many citizens in urban areas were unable to
pay rent and so were forced to live in improvised
shelters.
Mugabe’s solution was simply to get rid
of these shanty towns across Zimbabwe’s
major cities.
This was called ‘Operation Murambatsvina’,
or “Drive out the rubbish” – a large
scale Police operation which harassed, bullied
and coerced 700,000 residents into moving
to the countryside.
From 2008 to 2013, the coalition with Tsvangirai
had some positive effects in curbing inflation.
But since Mugabe reasserted complete control
in 2013, he returned to his former inflation-inducing
policies.
How long could it last?
A Bloodless Correction
In the second half of the 2010s unemployment
in Zimbabwe rose to 80 percent.
The public health system, once the best in
Africa, had collapsed.
And yet Mugabe, Grace and their family appeared
to spend lavishly on luxury goods and travel
frequently to the Far East – both for shopping
sprees and to seek treatment in expensive
private clinics.
In 2014, apparently inspired by Grace, Mugabe
removed his vice-president Joice Majuru and
replaced her with staunch loyalist Emmerson
Mnangagwa.
This move coincided with the elevation of
Grace to a leadership post in ZANU-PF, the
ruling party.
It appeared as though Mugabe was setting the
stage for Grace to succeed him as the new
Executive President.
The first lady was not a popular candidate,
especially not amongst the military.
On the 7th of November 2017, shortly before
new presidential elections, Mugabe fired his
vice-president.
The military saw this a sign of Grace’s
impending appointment to the vice-presidency.
One week later, the Generals occupied Harare,
arrested the Mugabes and placed them under
house arrest.
It was clearly a coup, although military spokesmen
described it as a ‘bloodless correction’.
Vice-President Mnangagwa was sworn in as President
in the same month.
Robert and Grace were allowed to live in relative
calm inside their 24-bedroom home in Harare
and even to travel frequently to Singapore.
Mugabe was being treated there for a long-term
illness, apparently cancer.
Back in August 2019, President Mnangawa revealed
that Robert Mugabe had been hospitalised in
Singapore for the past few months.
Then, on Friday the 6th of September Mnangawa
announced that former President Mugabe, now
aged 95, had died in Singapore.
“It is with the utmost sadness that I announce
the passing on of Zimbabwe’s founding father
and former President, Comrade Robert Mugabe.
Mugabe was an icon of liberation, a pan-Africanist
who dedicated his life to the emancipation
and empowerment of his people.
His contribution to the history of our nation
and continent will never be forgotten.”
On that we can agree: his contribution of
political violence, ethnic cleansing, corruption,
and mismanagement will certainly
not be forgotten.